Welcome everybody, to the
FP101x functional programming MOOC.
I'm really happy that we can do this one
as a MOOC with exercises and
everything.
Let's get started
immediately. One thing that I wanted
to tell you before we get going
is that this is a MOOC about functional
programming that's what the title says
FP101 functional programming. This is
not a course on Haskell, were using
Haskell
as a functional language but we're not
learning to program Haskell per se.
Let me tell you a little bit
of a story.
I travel a lot, going to conferences,
giving courses et cetera
and during those travels I have ample
time to watch TV.
One night I was zapping through the channels
and there was one of those survival
shows
where this guy was trying to make up
camp at night and trying to make a fire
but his matches were wet.
He could have gotten in panic and said:
my matches are wet I cannot make a fire.
What he did instead is he took a
cell phone
and his knife and he
took the battery out of his cell phone,
opened the battery
and then the battery started to combust.
That's what he used to start a fire.
And this is the same
attitude that I want to teach you in
this course.
While we're learning to do
functional programming using Haskell so
Haskell's our matches,
when at work you don't have matches
available
you still can do functional programming.
Sometimes you have to smash your
cell phone
and open your battery to start a fire.
Don't think that this is about
Haskell per se, we're going to teach
functional programming
using Haskell.
Alright, let's get
started then.
What's the problem that we're trying to
solve? The problem
is the so called software crisis.
We all know
as developers that writing code is
pretty difficult.
We're writing huge programs and
what we need to do is to reduce the
time
and the cost of development.
We want to deliver software fast
and we want to deliver correct software.
The question is
how can we make programs
such that that we are confident that our
programs work
and how can we make code
such that this code is delivered fast.
It doesn't take years to deliver but
it takes
months or as long as it needs to be.
One way to do that, and we see this now
in all modern programming languages, is to
add features to our languages
that allow programs to be written
clearly concisely and at a high level of
abstraction.
And the techniques that we use in these
modern languages
are all based on functional programming.
These techniques
are all based on concepts from the
lambda calculus.
And Haskell is a
functional language that is pure and
therefore
a really good vehicle to teach these
concept.
Functional languages
therefore provide a very elegant framework
to write code at a high level of
abstraction.
But as I said, Haskell is just our
vehicle.
What we learn in this course, you
will be able to apply this
to any language even if you're programming
in assembly
or in Java or in PHP
or in JavaScript, all the ideas that you
will learn here
you can apply immediately
in whatever language you're happening
to use.
What is a functional programming
language?
The ideas about that
vary, there's no real clear
definition.
If we take a very purist approach a
functional language
is a language in which we program using
mathematical functions.
And that definition applies to Haskell,
which is a pure language, one of the very
few
functional programming languages that is
pure. But of course
and when I say that we can use these
techniques to program also in other
languages
we cannot use that definition.
What will use in this course is the
following definition:
functional programming
is a style of programming in which
expressions are more important than
using statements.
What we want to do is: we want to
compose programs using expressions
and these expressions deliver a value so
we take two expressions that deliver a
value
and compose them in a bigger expression.
Compare and contrast that with writing
your program using statements.
When you compose statements the
statements have an implicit side-effect
on the global state and they
communicate values via that global
state.
Whereas in an expression based
programming style expressions return
values
and we compose these values directly.
A functional programming language
is a language that supports and
encourages
writing code using expressions.
As I said before, most modern
languages
now support this style.
And they support the style
specifically by supporting lambda
expressions.
We'll see examples of functional
programming
in many many languages as we progress
through this course. Let's
start with our first fragment of code
here.
This is some old-fashioned Java
where we're computing the sum of the
integers from one to ten.
The way we do that, as I said, in the
traditional imperative
style, this is based by doing
statements. The first thing we do
is we declare a variable total
of type int. We initialize it with zero
and then we write a for loop with a
loop variable.
That int i, that you see there and then we
assign to that the total
variable:
total variable + i. Here you see that
the program is written
in an imperative style.
We have statements,
we have mutable state and we
imperatively execute statement after
statement
updating the state to compute the result.
Now here is how you would write that same
program
in Haskell. The first thing you see is
that it's
much more concise but the other thing is
that there's no statement. It's just
two expressions.
The expression you see
here
on the right. One dot dot ten.
Creates a list of the integers from one
to ten.
And then we just sum those integers up.
So here you see that we're composing
the code by having an expression.
One that creates this list from one to ten
and then we apply that value
to a function sum that will sum things
up for us. In Java 8
you can write the same code
using Java 8 streams, we will
dive deeper into Java 8 and a future
lesson but for now here is the way
we do this in Haskell.
Thank you
and see you in part two.